la politique sanitaire de jaillir ball
somaro examiné au peigne fin une
commission d' enquête du sénat cherche à
établir les responsabilités du
gouvernement dans la crise du coc vie 19
au brésil ce mardi l'ancien ministre de
la santé
luis enrique mende d'état a été entendu
par les parlementaires
aujourd'hui en tant que citoyen quel 110
mille morts me sépare du résident à ce
jour pressenti pour être candidat lors
de la prochaine élection présidentielle
en 2022
luis enrique mende d'état a été limogé
en mars 2020 après avoir défendu la
distanciation physique pour tenter de
freiner les contaminations devant la
commission denquête l'ex ministre a
appelé le président à suivre les
recommandations du ministère de la santé
nous recommandons expressément à la
présidence de la république de changer
de position
en suivant les recommandations du
ministère de la santé
car l'adoption de mesures dans le sens
contraire peut générer un effondrement
du système de santé et des conséquences
très graves pour la santé de la
population brésilienne deuxième pays le
plus endeuillé par la pandémie
le brésil a enregistré un nouveau record
mensuel de mort en avril avait 80 2266
d'essai pour tenter d'endiguer la
propagation du coffee 19 sur son
territoire le pays soit mettre la
priorité sur la vaccination au brésil le
vaccin chinois corona vac constitue 77%
des doses inoculé problème selon le site
d'information brésilien g1 cette
capitale d'état comme belo horizonte où
porto alegre ont dû suspendre
l'injection d'et seconde dose du sérum
chinois la faute à un manque de doses de
vaccins la semaine dernière la
confédération nationale des
municipalités affirmé que 30 % des
communes brésilienne était à court de
doses pour les secondes injections
la sixième édition de l' enquête menée
par la confédération nationale des
municipalités pour comprendre le
panorama de l'affrontement de kovy 19
montre que 869 municipalité était sans
vaccin pour l'application de la deuxième
dose dans le délai
prévue par le rapport de vaccination il
manquait déjà la fourniture de la
première dose aux groupes prioritaires
pour 673 entités locales
dans le même temps le gouvernement
brésilien refuse d'utiliser le vaccin
russe public v une décision jugée
politique par moscou malgré la situation
sanitaire compliqué les brésil n'impose
pas de restrictions strictes à sa
population à sao paulo
les mesures anti coville ont même été
assouplies